[Musique]
mais t'as pas eu peur ça c'est la
question qu'on m'a le plus posé ces
quatre dernières années
alors vous me direz mais qu'est ce que
tu as fait est bien
contre toute attente je ne suis pas
parti m'expliquerai dans un pays en
guerre
je n'ai pas été kidnappés par un groupe
terroriste où je n'ai pas eu à me battre
contre une maladie grave
non moi il y a quatre ans j'ai
soudainement ouvert les yeux et je me
suis offert le plus beau des cadeaux
la liberté j'ai tout quitté d'une vie
peut-être chouette sur le papier mais
qui ne me correspondait plus du tout
j'ai lâché paris le job de rêve dans lux
homme parfait le duplex avec vue sur
notre dame et surtout un bon gros
sentiment de vide et je me suis allé
réaliser mon plus grand rêve faire le
tour du monde et donc je suis parti avec
mon sac à dos mon grand sourire
on a les saintes pour rio la confiance
en bandoulière parcourir ce monde
pendant près de trois années en espérant
remettre un peu de sens dans tout ça est
un peu de vie dans mes années et du sens
dieu sait que j'en ai trouvé et que la
vie que je me crée depuis est aligné
utile et profondément épanouissante
pilou mais rien n'y fait peur peur peur
avant mon voyage pendant depuis on ne me
parle que de ça parce que cette
transition de vie figurez vous que j'en
ai parlé au monde je les communiqués via
des textes sur internet donc des retours
sur ma situation
finalement j'en ai eu des milliers je
vais vous donner un petit aperçu
si je reviens paraît mais j'ose pas toi
margot avant de partir tu avais pas peur
partir
en étant une femme n'avait pas peur
qu'il t'arrive quelque chose une maladie
un accident de te faire voler violer
agressé plus philosophique parfois tu
avais pas peur de réaliser qu'en fait on
rêve d'enfant n'était qu'une illusion ou
que le bonheur n'existe que lorsqu'il
est partagé et depuis tu as décidé de
rentrer t'as pas peur de rentrer depuis
aimer la france 2 par trouver tes
marques d'avoir envie de repartir tout
de suite et dans un autre registre aussi
parfois tu m'inspires avec ton
changement de vie je serai bien pareil
j'ai la trouille de démissionner j'ai
peur de par trouver autre chose de
manquer de talents d'idées de clients de
temps d'argent et moi je suis là de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique
et je réponds à chaque peur à chaque
lecteur à chaque message que je reçois
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour par la peur de
trop qui la prend en pleine face sans
prévenir chez au costa rica
quand je réalise mais en fait ce monde
entier est mort de trouille et ça ne
choque personne
pourquoi ce mot peur sans cesse tout le
temps parce que et eau pour rappel dans
mon cas en tout cas c'est quand même
l'histoire d'une fille qui change de vie
pour le meilleur et qui réalise son rêve
alors est ce que c'est si difficile
d'imaginer qu'au delà de la peur elle a
pu ressentir ne serait ce qu'un tout
petit peu d'enthousiasmé que c'est pas
de ça dont on lui parle faut qu'on me
rappellent à quel moment l'humanité
toute entière s'est mise à ne plus
prendre les choses que sous l'angle de
l' angoisse
j'ai peur donc je suis c'est ça le
nouveau truc à la mode
non moi j'ai mieux à vous proposer une
autre voie est possible
laissez-moi vous embarquer dans l'un des
plus beaux enseignements de ce fameux
grand voyage vous êtes prêts c'est parti
alors déjà j'aimerais qu'on comprenne
ensemble maintenant quelque chose de
très important
la peur notre peur
un coup bon nombre d'industries sont
bâtis sur celle qui fait finalement de
nous des consommateurs plutôt docile et
fidèles qui en redemandent même
au delà de ce qu'elle nous coûte et donc
rapporte à d'autres en armes en allant
en assurance en systèmes de protection
en traitements divers et variés pour ne
pas vieillir ne pas grossir et bien nous
coûte surtout nos rêves nos projets
votre audace et du coup nos vies à côté
desquels on passe parfois à face à force
de ne pas oser se lancer et ça à mes
yeux c'est bien trop cher payé ensuite
rappelons que la peur à l'origine est
utile en tout cas à petites doses
en cas de danger précis sa fonction est
de rassembler l'intégralité enfin l'ami
la totalité de nos capacités physiques
afin de nous permettre au choix de
contre attaquer ou de nous enfuir donc
la peur en nous évitant la douleur
physique ou la mort est bien là permis à
la race humaine de survivre mais
aujourd'hui elles n'empêchent carrément
de vivre car de la petite dose on est
passé à la perfusion quasi quotidiennes
notre usage actuel de la peur va bien au
delà de sa fonction physiologique
première d'autant plus que seulement 8 %
de nos angoisses sont basées sur des
menaces réelles
toutes les autres sont le fruit de nos
projections mentales à nous tous qui
vivons bien trop dans nos têtes alors
regardez plutôt
tu pars waouh mais t'as pas peur tu
rentres tu n'as pas peur ait eu trait
installe en europe et t'as pas peur
vous voyez bien que la peur n'est pas
dans la situation observée mais bien
dans l'esprit de celui qu'il observe
aujourd'hui et c'est bien dommage on
dégaine l' angoisse comme premier
réflexe c'est normal en même temps on
nous y conditionne chaque jour mais nous
pouvons aller contre ce conditionnement
nous pouvons désapprendre ce que nous
avons appris
oui appris vous m'avez bien entendu car
elle nous est devenu tellement naturel
peur qu'on oublie qu'elle n'a pas
toujours été présente le bébé ne n'est
qu'avec deux peurs celle de tomber ou
des bruits trop fort toutes les autres
sont des réactions acquise par l'enfant
au cours de ses premières années de vie
ou développer plus tard par l'adulte il
faut comprendre qu'en fait on apprend à
craindre
ces choses que nos parents notre culture
notre société craignent que l'on en ait
une expérience directe ou non d'ailleurs
je vous donne un exemple
moi j'avais peur des mygales bien avant
d'en croiser une alors je vous dis pas
ma surprise quand lorsque mais lorsque
pendant mes deux mois en amazonie j'ai
découvert que les enfants même tout
petit les adorait et jouer avec vous
voyez je crois que c'est là bas au coeur
de cette forêt la plus dense du monde
que j'ai commencé à questionner mon
rapport à la peur et je sais que c'est
là-bas aussi sur les routes de cette
amérique latine que j'ai parcouru en
long en large et en travers que j'ai
commencé à découvrir et à pratiquer
l'autre voie car justement des voix il
n'y en a que deux la peur est l'amour
enfin je devrais plutôt dire la peur ou
l'amour car justement c'est l'une ou
l'autre et le comprendre ça a changé ma
vie je vous explique
vous l'aurez peut-être compris à ce
stade
mon voyage a été plus initiatique que
touristique et donc mes expériences
spirituelles mais rencontre mais
échanges à coeur ouvert mes lectures
aussi m'ont amené à comprendre mais
encore plus en fait à ressentir à quel
point au sein de l'être humain il n'y a
que deux élans deux impulsions deux
émotions racines finalement la peur ou
l'amour et donc
si l'on décortique chaque parole ou
comportement d'un être humain
finalement à sa source qu'est ce que
l'on trouve soit un élan de peur une
fermeture une méfiance soit un élan
d'amour de confiance une ouverture
finalement et si j'insiste autant sur le
mot ou à chaque fois c'est pour une
bonne raison
peur et amour sont les deux extrémités
d'une même réalité
un peu comme le chaud et le froid le
jour et la nuit qui ne sont pas s'y
opposer aussi différents que l'on a
tendance à le croire
accepter de changer quelques instants
avec moi de perspectives
et si le chaud et le froid et l'ombre et
la lumière n'était finalement pas opposé
s'il était la même réalité donc dans un
cas la température dans l'autre la
lumière simplement expérimenté à des
intensités différentes d'accord et si
donc le froid n'était que l'absence de
chaleur et l'ombre l'absence de lumière
en fait en présence de l'un on ne peut
pas expérimenté l'autre peur amour
chaud-froid jour nuit sont en fait comme
les deux réelles les deux mêmes faces
d'une même les deux faces d'une même
médaille
on expérimente donc l'une ou l'autre
mais on peut jamais observé les deux en
même temps
la peur vous m'avez suivi la peur et
donc à l'amour ce que le froid est au
chaud est ce que l'ombre est à la
lumière son absence
la peur est l'absence d'amour
ce qui veut dire par définition qu'à
chaque fois qu'on choisit la peur et
bien on ne choisit pas l'amour et moi ça
ça m'a l'air tu vu la place toujours
plus grande que la peur prend dans nos
vies et dans nos sociétés en revanche ce
qui me rassure c'est que j'ai vraiment
compris à quel point l'être humain
pouvait choisir son expérience c'est à
dire que l'on peut consciemment décidé
d'observer une même situation sous un
angle ou sous un autre
et comment on fait ça et bien c'est très
très simple on se pose une question qui
tient en trois mots que ferait l'amour
ça peut-être l'air de rien comme ça mais
il ya un avant et un après cette
question dans ma vie cette question
c'est marianne williamson qui me l'a
offerte au détour d'une page de son
ouvrage de référence et c'est à mon tour
de vous l'offrir ce soir car c'est
important écart cette simple question
elle a un pouvoir immense celui de
remettre l'amour au centre et donc
d'offrir la possibilité d'une
transformation immédiate
votre expérience votre perception d'une
personne ou d'une situation change en un
instant regardez on va pratiquer
ensemble
que ferait l'amour à ma place là dans
cette situation je les reformuler parce
que je pense que c'est plus parlant que
ferait l'absence de peur à ma place là
dans cette situation qu'est-ce que moi
margot je penserai qu'est-ce que je
dirais qu est ce que je ferais là si je
n'avais pas peur d'être ridicule d'être
jugés d'être rejetée d'être moquée de
rater de perdre de mourir posez-vous
bien cette simple question
écoutez la réponse est ensuite penser ça
dit ça toujours plus de ça vous verrez
que là où la peur vous incite à la
timidité à l'immobilisme à la lâcheté à
la colère à l'égoïsme à la violence à la
condamnation au jugement à la à la
guerre finalement et bien votre coeur
lui vous incitera toujours à la
confiance à l'indulgence à la
bienveillance à la compassion aux dons
au parti pris de ne pas juger au partage
à l'intimité à la générosité à la paix
la voie de la peur ou la voie de l'amour
où je pourrais dire aussi la voie du
mental où la voix du coeur qui
allons-nous choisir d'écouter c'est
important chacun nous emmènera à davy
finalement très différente donc choisi
son bien et c'est important pour soi
mais pour ce monde aussi qu'à chaque
instant on prenne la bonne décision pour
soi pourquoi
et bien moi je crois profondément que
notre coeur nous emmènera plus loin dans
des vies plus alignés qui nous
ressemblent davantage et potentiellement
plus épanouissante
prenons exemple j'avais très très envie
de partir en voyage tout quitter et
partir ça ça me posait aucun problème
en revanche dès que je commençais à
penser au retour ça me paralyse l
angoisse
je me voyais revenir sans argent sans
emploi et sans amoureux et puis galéré à
retrouver les 3 alors comment j'ai fait
et bien j'ai fait vite j'ai pris ma
décision en moins de 7 jours
j'ai fait taire ma tête sinon évidemment
les doutes et les peurs aurait réussi à
me paralyser à paris et j'ai écouté mon
coeur est sincèrement je leur ferais
sans foi et d'ailleurs je les fais 100
fois ces quatre dernières années et
c'est ce qui explique selon moi que la
vie que je mène aujourd'hui est
radicalement différente de celle que
j'ai laissé à paris mon coeur m'a donné
du courage m'a donné les ailes pour
réaliser entre autres cent mille
kilomètres en amérique latine dont un
fini lance top dormir chez l'habitant
dans 12 pays habité au coeur de
l'amazonie dépassé ma peur de l'océan
des requins mais pas c'est aussi ma
timidité pour commencer à publier ces
textes sur internet
ce que je voulais inspirer les gens à se
poser ces mêmes questions en fait mon
coeur
il m'a permis de réaliser des tas de
défis le dernier en date
je vous laisse imaginer évidemment que
mon ventre c'est serré très fort quand
on m'a proposé ce tête mais j'ai
ressenti au moins autant d'enthousiasmé
alors j'ai choisi consciemment d'écouté
l'enthousiaste
attention je ne suis pas non plus en
train de vous dire de désormais foncer
tête baissée d'accepter tout ce qu on va
vous proposer
non moi la peur je recommande de la
remplacer par la prudence la prudence
c'est cette chose magique qui vous
mobilise et vous fait regarder à droite
et à gauche avant de traverser la route
tandis que la peur c'est cette chose
sournoise qui vous paralyse et vous
maintient potentiellement toute une vie
du même côté de cette route
bien sûr que j'étais consciente des
risques
bien sûr que j'ai été prudente dans ce
voyage de près de trois ans mais ça ne
m'a pas empêché de le vivre à ma manière
et manière c'est quoi ces confiance en
avant et je vous garantis que mon
sourire ma bonne humeur ma bienveillance
et ma gratitude mon ouvertes des portes
absolument partout car elle sont
universelles et c'est ça le dernière le
dernier truc que j'aimerais vous
partagez ce soir vous l'aurez compris
écoutez votre coeur
davantage que vos peurs c'est important
pour vous mais c'est crucial pour le
monde dans lequel on vit
nos sociétés sont devenues tellement
anxiogène que l'amour on est devenu
suspect oui suspect je pèse mes mots
vous avez déjà essayé vous de sourire
franchement à des inconnus dans la rue
moi oui tout le temps et bien c'est
consternant 8 sur 10 ont l'air surpris
carrément inquiet ou font comme s'il ne
m'avait pas vu 2 me sourit en retour
plus fou encore un tenter le bon jour où
le compliment à un ou une inconnu et
observer le carrément vous demandez ce
qu'il se demander ce qui vous prend ou
chercher la caméra cachée ça devient
difficile dans notre monde d'aider un
inconnu de porter des courses de donner
2 euros à quelqu'un qui manque pour
faire l'appoint à la caisse ou de porte
ou de ou d'aider une personne âgée à
traverser car elle va vous regarder de
travers
ben oui quoi vous êtes louche avec votre
gentillesse en revanche tous regarder
par terre dans le métro insulté un
inconnu au volant débat les anonymes en
tant qu à faire sa haine sur internet
harcelé un camarade de classe ou un
collègue ça c'est devenu plutôt banal eh
bien ce n'est pas le monde dans lequel
moi j'ai envie de vivre et vous non plus
j'en suis sûr alors c'est pour ça que je
suis là ce soir
dépassé ma peur pour nous rappeler à
quel point l'amour et la bienveillance
n'ont jamais tué personne
alors que la peur et la violence qui
peut en découler si alors le système de
la peur ne sera pas démantelée en un
jour j'en ai bien conscience
mais je sais aussi qu'il a besoin de
chacun d'entre nous pour commencer à
s'effriter
assumons d'être en décalage dans un
monde qui flippe et se contient assumons
d'aimer et d'oser nous lancer c'est
important c'est une question à se poser
une décision à prendre un camp à choisir
il n'y a pas de neutralité
tous ensemble nous pouvons réécrire
l'histoire consciemment régulièrement
faisant le choix du coeur sur la peur
activement enfin devenons des activistes
de l'amour et de la bienveillance
je vous préviens nous ressentirons à
nouveau la peur après avoir choisi
l'amour c'est naturel comme la lumière
peut s'éteindre après avoir été allumés
et bien c'est là justement à cet instant
qu'il est de notre responsabilité de la
rallumer cette lumière d'ouvrir grand
les volets et une par une
d'allumer une nuée de petites bougies
mère teresa disait ce monde se guérira
par des pensées d'amour une pensée à la
fois il n'existe pas de grandes actions
juste des petites actions accomplies
avec un grand amour c'est tellement
important
c'est tellement nécessaire est tellement
simple alors vous me direz il va donc
falloir que l'on sème pour s'en sortir
oui mais ne vous inquiétez pas comme le
disait romain gary n'ayez pas peur du
bonheur c'est qu'un bon moment à passer
et à cette question qu'on m'a si souvent
posée j'ai envie de vous répondre ce
soir si j'ai eu peur bien sûr un peu de
vous même peut-être beaucoup parfois
mais c'est pas grave
j'aime ça
[Applaudissements]